this is maya for stutter a tax expert a
feminist
and the protagonist in a bitter legal
battle about
sex gender and freedom of speech but
it's about having institutions that are
able to stand up
she believes the body someone is born
with determines their sex
and that this sex cannot be changed but
it's a belief that puts her at odds with
the rights of transgender people
at odds with the view that gender or how
someone identifies
is more important it's a belief that
cost her her job
and a belief she's fighting to have
legally protected
it's the ability to talk about material
reality
the reality is there are two sexes
but sex matters and sex matters for
health care
sex matters for other people's privacy
it matters for how we understand the
world
and imagine organizations
but to some this view is deeply
transphobic
her contract at the think tank where she
worked was not renewed
after colleagues complained about tweets
expressing it
she went to employment tribunal to argue
such beliefs should have legal
protection
but she lost the judge describing them
as incompatible with human dignity
and not worthy of respect in a
democratic society
her appeal is being heard next week if
i lose and this is not a protected
belief
then it's open season for
women in particular but for anybody who
speaks up about women's sex based rights
employers have to be able to think these
things through the judgement was
it was pretty resounding against you do
you accept that some of the things you
said
amounted to harassment in the eyes of
some and that that's what matters it's
how people perceive these things
no not at all there was nothing that i
did
that harassed anybody so if the belief
is protected that doesn't mean that
doesn't give you the ability to harass
or abuse anybody
her case has been extremely high profile
support from author jk rowling made it
international news
but it's caused hurt and distress many
transgender people say her views amount
to a denial of their existence
and threaten a respectful workplace if a
person
obtains a gender recognition certificate
they should have the full protection of
of the law if we undermine that then
that
fundamentally under undermines
protections for all
trans people in the uk trans
people in this country are being
vilified for something that's a
natural uh hormonal development of the
brain
in the womb whichever side prevails in
this appeal it will set an important
precedent that will have implications
beyond just the workplace it will
determine how you can be treated simply
for holding these beliefs
even if they're never acted upon either
side could take the case to the court of
appeal if they lose
the stakes are as high as the issue is
divisive
helen ann smith sky news